we've got a theme of sort of hypocrisy
or something much worse than hypocrisy
going here this next video this is ben
and jerry you know these hippie 60s ice
cream people they did an absolutely
debacle i mean a true disaster of an
interview with axios we've got about a
minute of it right here disagree with
the israeli government policy why not
just stop sales completely well
i disagree with the u.s policy
we couldn't stop selling in the u.s i
think it's fine to
be involved with
a country to be to be a citizen of a
country
and to protest
some of the some of the country's
actions
and
that's essentially
what we're doing in terms of israel we
hugely support israel's right to exist
but we are against a particular policy
you guys are big proponents of voting
rights why do you still sell ice cream
in georgia
texas abortion bans
why are you still selling there
i don't know
i mean i mean it's a it's an interesting
question
i don't know what
what that would accomplish
we're working on those issues of voting
rights and
i don't know i you know i mean i think
you ask a really good question and i
think
i'd have to sit down and think about it
for a bit
he'd have to sit down and think about it
for a bit he's half bernie sanders half
larry david we should have put the curb
music in there but it's just such a
perfect such a perfect example about how
these people don't think through
anything and by the way guys you're not
going to believe this those hippies
those peace loving progressive socialist
hippies they sold ben and jerry's uh
about 15 20 years ago for roughly 350
million dollars to unilever one of the
largest corporations in the entire world
uh but again is is hypocrisy calling it
hypocrisy is not quite enough is it
jesse
no it's not but i they're they're just
par for the course i mean you brought up
that they're huge bernie people and
bernie's a great example of this what
did he have three houses while espousing
all that communist crap crappy throws
out there but again this is not it's not
hypocrites that's what socialism is
that's what communism is it always works
out that way it's always for the
peasants right it's always for the ones
they should rule over it's never it's
never for them they all want the finer
things in life they just believe they
should rule and deny you the finer
things in life because they are the gods
that'll hand out the economy or hand out
the equality that they believe the world
should do that's that's that's why the
whole thing has been such a joke it's
why it's rejected all the time it's why
it fails all the time because nobody
nobody can take in that much power and
not want more of it or that much money
and not want more of it it fails all the
time for a reason and those guys are a
great example
sydney this kind of reminded me of the
sanjay gupta joe rogan thing from this
week that when basically these people
who are treated with kid gloves all the
time in media appearances when they have
to do something a little more long form
and i doubt that axios is like the most
difficult place you know that woman
she's perfectly fine obviously but like
i don't think this was like they walked
in thinking this would be the hardest
thing ever that they completely fold
because they really don't know what
they're talking about which is exactly
what happened to sanjay with rogan i
know and it's you know i don't know if
you guys are like me but i get the worst
secondhand embarrassment watching this
stuff because like that pause and he
goes i don't know oh my god i thought my
heart was going to explode it's so
awkward to listen to but i mean you're
right at the end of the day if you
receive no pushback on anything that you
ever say out in the world or ever put
out into the world as a general rule
when you do come into contact with
somebody who questioned you even in and
she was being very nice that interviewer
just by the way she's being very very
polite and very nice uh if you're if you
still can't answer a question then it
really goes to show that hey you haven't
thought through your position which i
think when it comes to ice cream people
i'm not really surprised by that in any
capacity because they do slacktivism
it's that thing where oh let's put a
colin kaepernick on a on an ice cream
tub and that's going to be the end of it
let's make our you know millions in
sales we'll manipulate the crap out of
the population then we take our money
home and we sit up on you know in our
nice little house away from all the
plebs and we go ha ha ha look we did a
good thing for the day so i don't know i
mean i'm not surprised by these people
being as dumb as uh two short planks
because that's kind of what they do but
they are really good at manipulating us
i think that's what's funny about it the
people who buy this i pity them elijah
the longer i do whatever it is that i do
here the more it's obvious to me that my
old former team pretty much everybody
and there's almost no exclusions to this
it's not necessarily that they're bad
people although there are some bad ones
at the top but pretty much everybody
just does not think about anything they
just think the world exists because it
should exist and it's the way they want
it to be and they have to keep you know
replicating it to be the way they want
it to be but they just don't think about
anything so then you get asked like the
most basic question and and you
completely freeze up
yeah i mean this comes in a world of
view i mean when you think the world's
been around for billions and billions of
years it always was and it always will
be then there's not much incentive to
really think about things it's just to
keep things going and if you think the
world's just a machine a mechanism with
no purpose then you don't need to have a
purpose you just need to react and so
that's where world view largely comes
into how society forms and these people
are just not awake they don't they don't
process information in any tangible way
and dave this makes me miss i'll tell
you this so this is sort of a white pill
for me because
you know this makes me miss the college
wars of like 2016 2017. those are the
good old days oh yeah you were right in
the thick of that i mean i remember
going to protest i was laughing right
now i was watching some old protest
footage
going out there you know asking people
you know about donald trump and people
telling me donald trump was hitler's
nephew and asking them like i thought
they were joking and then being like no
no i he is and you're like
okay so apparently
being mentally ill is no longer a
disability it's a common trait of our
current society and so i you know i mean
we remember that and these people were
stupid and they've learned to shut up
they've shut up and they've given their
mouthpieces to the forefront they become
militant because we mocked them we made
fun of them and the sad part is as they
didn't learn
to become smarter they are not trying to
become smarter like jesse said because
they're not hypocrites because they're
dumb the people in power have just
realized that it's not about using these
dumb people at the forefront anymore
they've gone full military industrial
complex communist by using now policy
and using the government to do their
battles for them like the days of the
brown shirts and believing ben and
jerry's is going to accomplish leftist
goals is totally out the window nobody
even relies on these people anymore
because they really don't know what the
hell they're talking about and
unfortunately in some ways they're kind
of victims of their own ignorance